elvis presley's family are leaving their
mark on hollywood with three generations
representing the king of rock and roll
at the hand in footprint ceremony at the
tcl chinese theater in hollywood yeah
elvis's ex-wife priscilla presley was
joined by their daughter lisa marie and
granddaughters riley harper and finley
and yes our favorites awesome butler and
baslerman were also in attendance as
they gear up for the highly anticipated
release of the elvis biopic this friday
i am so excited to see this and
priscilla herself has had nothing but
praise for the biopic and austin's
portrayal so it was only a uh so it was
only a given he introduced the presley
family as they made hollywood history
take a look and we'll see you tomorrow
bye bye
ladies and gentlemen
the presley family
i remember coming here years ago going
my gosh to have your hand print on here
or your feet print and signed must be
quite a deal and it is
um
uh certainly had elvis lived he would
have been given this honor
and proudly become a part of this great
hollywood tradition and hollywood
history
this is just a huge honor for us
to speak for me and my family and my
children
biggest honor we're so grateful i'll be
brief
um thank you for coming thank you for
inviting us
and um it's very special moment for all
of us we feel incredibly honored so
thank you
i think it's safe to say that elvis
would be so proud
to
see the loves of his life
his family
here today to honor him along with all
of you